we're gonna have some dancing in this
video i hope so okay i mean i'm not i'm
hoping the girls are gonna be dancing
[Music]
it's good to see you in person though
you know what i'm saying i know it's a
reunion right because not only do we get
new music but we are on the set of your
new music video
i love it you're also surprising fans
with a very special guest appearance in
this video becca tilly i feel like you
can't do this video and not have becca
in it right oh absolutely not yeah i
mean like we needed a bachelor alumni
and becca's been in two seasons of the
bachelor
so she had to be a part of it and you
know third time's a charm
does she have ptsd at all reliving like
the bachelor nation of it all i'm not
sure yet i could see myself
him in a tuxedo me in a dress walking
down the aisle
i think that she's just really excited
and i'm really excited for people to see
the ending of the video so make sure to
watch to the very end how do you think
bachelor nation will react to this video
i think the bachelor nation's gonna love
this video i'm a huge bachelor fan so i
really tried to celebrate the show
quite honestly because i love it so i
think bachelor nation is gonna love it
and i i think they're gonna love the
surprise at the end too did you consult
becca when you were kind of thinking
about thinking up and dreaming up this
video about like what should i include
what do i have to include yeah we
definitely talked about it and obviously
like i watch bachelor every monday
nights with my girlfriends and so like i
talked to them about they're like oh my
gosh you have to have this like you have
to have someone eliminate themselves you
have to do this and so it's going to be
fun you have to watch the whole video
it's going to be wild because he's also
doing the limo entrances y'all doing
limo entrances honestly my favorite part
let's talk about the song first because
obviously with your songwriting i mean
you really know how to tell a story and
there's always like a takeaway right so
what's the message behind for the girls
for my new single for the girls i really
just wanted to create an anthem
celebrating women i love women they
inspire me they support me they help me
keep going and i was like i don't have a
song for them and so here we are who are
the
[Music]
girls to me about the concept and how
you came up with it i relate to the
bachelor but i'm like i want to be the
bachelor for the girls yes obviously i
love reality television i love like
reality dating shows like love is blind
and the bachelor huge fan and so i feel
like we don't really get a lot of
representation for our community
and i was like well this is a good
opportunity we have 15 queer contestants
all trying to find love
and i will be giving out the flowers
you're giving up the roses you're giving
out the roses
[Applause]
how does it feel to have that power and
to kind of live out a fantasy honestly i
think the energy is just gonna be so
wonderful and i'm excited for people to
get to watch this music video and get to
see themselves on screen because i'm a
huge fan but i don't even get to see
myself on screen a lot of the time so i
feel like it'll be a really good feeling
yeah do you feel like that day will come
though where we'll finally see like yeah
an lgbtq lead on one of these actually
this is the start you know we're
starting uh a movement they need to see
it to believe it okay exactly this is it
yeah we're so much fun to watch you
should totally watch us and we'll also
bring the drama don't worry the drama
will be there that's why we watch this
we'll be there the chaos will be there
get out of here we're going to send you
packages
[Applause]
i'm putting all of my heart and soul
into this music video and um i'm so
excited well speaking of that you're
also directing it which is i think this
is your 12th music video that you've
self-directed which is insane 11th or
12th i'm not sure i haven't counted it
but you probably know better um carry
the one yeah um yeah it's just i think
as an artist i just have a specific
vision and i think that i just i just
love directing i love storytelling it
makes it a little complicated but it's
it's so much fun obviously in this video
you are trying to find your one true
love what about you know your own
journey and finding love do you hope
inspires people who watch your story not
to get too deep but with so many
anti-lgbtq
plus bills being passed right now it's
very challenging to feel hopeful for our
community and so i wanted to create this
safe space of art my fans being able to
watch this video seeing people that look
like them thriving being their true
authentic selves and knowing that like
legislation trying to take that away
from us is not going to take away our
existence our worth our truth and the
ability to find love
[Music]
[Music]
you've done that with your music before
this too you know why is it so important
to kind of be that pillar or even just
an example to our community out there i
think it's just important for everyone
as a human being to
try to be their most authentic self and
share that with people because i feel
like being who you truly are and sharing
your experiences and you know your
struggles inspires others to keep going
and i think that that's everyone's just
a job right on this earth i feel like
absolutely amen to that so this is the
first single off the upcoming album
right yeah finally i've been waiting i'm
not gonna lie i'm gonna wait
it's exciting because you put up bombs
you know uh with the message behind it
like i mentioned but talk to me about
the upcoming album what's the vibe and
what do you want fans to know about i
guess this next era of haley kyoko um i
feel like this next era of myself i've
really tried to look inwards and kind of
refine who i am and have a lot of
self-reflection and so i really feel
like this
next chapter of haley kyoko is a more
refined
stronger more mature authentic version
of myself and i think that'll really
translate through the sonics of the
records um i i was very meticulous of
which songs made the record um and just
every song is just like
so hopefully that's the plan
[Music]
your songwriting is so personal and it's
so honest so i feel like you probably
like really
dig deep each time you're kind of
writing the next thing so what surprised
you about yourself like what did you
learn about yourself when you were
writing this next album what was so
interesting because it's been a multiple
year journey of working on this album is
i was writing this album and as i was
writing it the album was helping me get
through things so i would write a song
and the album was supporting me through
the album process which i've never had
before my first album i wrote it it was
done we're like cool but this one i've
sat with it i've listened to it it's
it's helped me um work through things
and so i feel like even closer to this
album more than ever i love it uh are
there any collaborations on this that
you can tease
not that i can tease
but um i'm really excited for you guys
to listen to the album and i'm so
excited for you all to hear for the
girls it's such a fun summer song it
makes you shake your booty we're gonna
dance yeah are we gonna dance
in the treatment you said something
about you're also going to play to some
of those lesbian tropes and stereotypes
right so i have to there's gonna be
u-haul right
pulling up pulling up to the spot yes
look out for those little easter eggs
[Music]
you